Jeremy Foley, Director and Co-Writer: THE
FACELESS MAN is a man who is down-and-out.
He’s depressed.
He wakes up one morning and his face has been
transformed into a mirror.
This story was adapted from a short story
that my father wrote in a reaction to The
Great Recession.
And I think it certainly was how he was feeling
Journalist voiceover: “This situation is
that many Americans have lost their jobs and
they’ve lost their homes.
Frankly, a lot of the ones I spoke to feel
like they’ve lost their identity.
They don’t see a recovery.
Instead they must find a new purpose in today’s
world.”
“Gimme a break."
Jeremy Foley: I remember thinking that idea
(a man searching for his lost identity) would
resonate with a lot of people.
Sara O’Reilly, Producer: This story had
a lot of humor but also some serious themes
and all of that we wanted to preserve when
we were adapting it.
It’s like the spirit of this whimsical adventure
that the faceless man goes on.
Bill O’Leary, “The Faceless Man”: I
personally love juxtaposition of comedy and
tragedy that are right on top of each other
and something I really enjoyed performing.
“Nothing to see here.”
Even within this fantastic story.
I really wanted to bring the guy’s pain
and effort.
“I’m sorry.
I just woke up like this.
Please don’t arrest me.”
Sara O’Reilly: When we first started figuring
out how we were going to make this film (how
were we going to make a man with a mirror
for a face), we decided we were going to make
it practically.
Will Myers, Director of Photography: I wasn’t
quite sure what the ins-and-outs were going
to be and so it required a lot testing just
to make sure of the reflection aspect and
whether or not it was going to get the desired
effect, if it was going to show the camera
and those kinds of things.
“It is weird because you do not change in
size no matter how much close I move the camera.”
Yes it was a huge pain in the a$$ but it looks
so much better and I’m glad we did it this
way.
Jeremy Foley: The next step was about the
fabrication of the mask.
Sara O’Reilly: So we hired a company called
Rogue Planet Laboratories which is Ian Goodwin’s
shop and worked with him to really develop
a mask.
We did a full life cast of Billy’s face
where they pour all of the goop all over his
head and make a mold which we have like a
perfect bust of Billy now in our living room.
And then using that mold he then sculpted
that shape of what the mask what was going
to be with clay so we kind of had an idea
of what it was going to look like.
Then he molded it with silicone and silicone
kind of looked like skin but it’s really
pale, so once they apply that to Billy’s
face, he then had to paint it.
So he airbrush paints it and blends it perfectly
with Billy’s skin.
So for three hours every morning Billy was
in the chair and make-up.
Bill O’Leary: Just the work they did was
just mind blowing.
And for me, I’ve been doing this work a
long time and I’ve never had an experience
before.
Sara O’Reilly: It was important to be able
to have the mirror on and off because we wanted
Billy to be able to breathe and drink water
and eat and eat cylindric foods or things
on forks.
I can’t imagine doing what he did, it was
very impressive.
Bill O’Leary: It’s a lot like 14 hours
of him just taking his hands and pressing
them on your face around your eyes in 106
degree….yeah like that!
For 14 hours..
Ian Goodwin: Except it’s not as much fun.
Bill O’Leary: But not as much fun!
“Action!”
Jeremy Foley: A lot of different disciplines,
a lot of different filmmaking techniques went
into making this short film.
Will Myers: There are a couple of Easter egg
digital shots in the film but 98% of it is
all practical.
Jeremy Foley: While the practical aspects
of it work well as the mirror in terms of
a mirror, performance-wise and lighting-wise
and everything else that came along with it
became exponentially harder.
“Down…down…okay…now to the right.”
Jeremy Foley: So we had this fun thing on
the set called “The Mirror Game.”
“Tilt up your chin…yeah…closer…closer.
Head down…tilt down…and tilt it left…tilt
left…head up.”
With the mirror we working working always
with the tiniest degree of give or take.
If Billy had turned his head just a half an
inch to the left or just a half an inch to
the right, it would have revealed ten people
standing in that corner.
Bill O’Leary: I was having to just over
and over and over I mean crazed and then I
come and see a kid and they’d go “No,
you are off by a billionth of an inch.”
And then I’d go “Okay, I’ve got to go
see a kid.”
And then “No!
Now you are off by a quarter of an inch.”
Aaarrgggh!!!
“Go out a bit.”
I will never have difficult sharing a footmark
again in my life.
Those are easy, this was tricky.